I want to congratulate you on this court
case there is nothing worse in my book
as somebody who creates stuff somebody
accusing you of a rip-off I read in the
paper you sat down with the jury and I
think this is great and you took out
your guitar and you said to the jury you
think I ripped off this song I'm Gonna
Play you something now and show you how
similar things can be what did you play
for that jury if I was the jury yeah
what did you say to them so it was um
so my one is um when your legs don't
work like they used to before and then
there's Have I Told You Lately That I
loved you and then um
people get ready there's a train coming
um and then uh what was the looks like
we made it look how far we've come my
baby I know she breaks just like a woman
I mean there was there was a hundred and
one songs that and that was like
scratching the surface there was like
101 you know there's um uh I guess you
say it's it's really and what I was
saying is like yes it's a chord sequence
that you hear on successful songs but if
you say that a song in 1973 owns this
then what about all the songs that came
before we found songs like from like the
1700s that had similar uh melodic stuff
and then there was like huge songs in
the 50s and huge songs in the 60s and
it's just no one's saying that songs
shouldn't be copyrighted but you just
can't copyright a chord sequence you
just can't I'm really glad it's over man
it was like eight years of that and
eight years yeah and this is my like
livelihood and this is the thing that
I've worked my entire life to do and
have to have someone like disbeliever
and diminish it and just say that you've
stolen it I really felt like I had to
take a stand and and go to it and either
way you lose because you you spend God
knows what to win the case and then you
don't get that back and if you lose the
case you lose God no so either way
you're sort of in a and then there's
also the stain on your reputation for
the holy life there's always a question
mark of the headline of Ed Sheeran stole
this award that that doesn't go away so
you have to sort of take that risk of
like I'm gonna go really public with
this take it to court and hope for the
best basically but you missed your
grandmother's funeral because yeah court
case could you have said to the judge
hey by the way can I have a day to go to
my grandmother's funeral well uh it was
in Ireland that was the only thing and
the thing with it like I thought the
case would end Monday or Tuesday and the
funeral was on Wednesday and then on the
Thursday or the Monday I can't remember
what their side suddenly randomly called
my manager to like it wasn't in the
schedule and they randomly called him
and they they questioned him for what
whatever it was and that made it spill
over it's uh it's it's a shame I won't
get that time back and she was a great
woman uh did you get a lot of phone
calls from other musicians thanking you
oh man well yeah it was sort of like in
the process you know someone like Elton
John Don Jones he sent me a really nice
message Taylor congratulations dated me
when I won the case you know everyone
was saying to me after I said uh if I
lost I'd quit uh songwriting and they
were like no you wouldn't and I really
honestly think I probably would have
done because it would it just takes the
joy out of it if you can't sit down and
go I I can't use a c chord to a G chord
because someone in the 60s used a sequel
to A G chord it it it just sucks the fun
out of it
foreign